[Music]
since the inception of the Wii Nintendo
has gone down a different design path
with its consoles rather than wage a war
of processing power with Microsoft and
Sony the company sought to fundamentally
rethink Hardware the Nintendo switch
continues this out-of-the-box thinking
with a hybrid form factor after using it
for a week I'm glad to say that the
hardware has a lot of potential and
marks a strong return to form for the
company like the Wii U gamepad before it
the switch offers a six point two inch
touchscreen with a joke on controllers
attached it's nine point four by four
point one by one inch frame make it
significantly smaller than the gamepad
while the dimensions of the display are
the same the switches screen looked far
better it's bright glossy 1280 by 720 p
screen certainly isn't the sharpest
panel on the market but it offers a
moderate to 36.8 pixel per inch density
above the touch screen the switch houses
its power button volume rocker exhaust
FET game card slot and 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack
under the device there's a USB C power
port on the back of the unit there's a
kickstand that you can pull out this
also reveals the micro SD card slot
underneath the kickstand itself only
offers one angle and it also feels a bit
flimsy I tested the neon red and blue
switch variant I have to say that the
Joye cons look surprisingly bright and
charming in person it's easy to attach
the joy constants which they generate a
very satisfying snap when you slide them
in place removing them requires a little
more care as you need to press down on a
small button on the back of both
controllers to release them the left and
right cons are somewhat mirrored forms
of each other both controllers offer
face and directional buttons along with
a joystick the sticks themselves are
pretty short and can't match the travel
distance of Microsoft solution but they
are much taller than the Nintendo DS's
sticks and are serviceable whereas the
Wii U gamepad looked and felt a bit like
a fisher-price toy the switch feels
sturdy overall this is even more
impressive when you consider that at
point 9 pounds with the joy con
controllers attached the switch is
slightly lighter than the gamepad having
spent several hours playing with a
switch on the go I can say that it never
felt uncomfortably heavy the switch is
also more portable than I imagined
with a joi cons attached the device can
fit into large pants pockets though will
most likely jut out a little the switch
is ideally suited for backpacks but on
some loose-fitting slacks can most
likely get away with putting both joi
cons into one pocket and the console on
the other when you want to play the
switch on your TV you'll need
to insert it into the included switch
dog putting the switch on the TV you'll
probably want to connect the droidcon
controllers to the included grip
peripheral which feels surprisingly
comfortable and ergonomic underneath the
hood the switch uses a heavily
customized nvidia tegra system on a chip
that's based on the arm instruction set
in layman's terms that basically means
the console uses a souped up tablet
processor because the switch is based on
a mobile SOC it's not a processing
powerhouse in Legend of Zelda breath of
the wild there are jaggies and
occasional framerate dips when the
console is docked and rendering the game
at 900 P it tends to dip when it's too
much happening on the screen
interestingly I didn't notice the same
performance issue when I played Zelda on
the go this is not to say that the
switch isn't capable of delivering
beautiful graphics
despite its occasional technical hiccups
birth of the wild is a beautiful game
with lush colors and expansive vistas
it's far and away the most beautiful
game I've ever seen rendered on a mobile
processor the switch uses a tiny fan and
it's super quiet it never got obscenely
hot either the switches power efficient
design is most likely why it's temps are
so moderate the switch comes with 32
gigabytes of storage when you factor an
operating system overhead this leaves
you with 25.9 gigabytes of usable space
that's not a lot but the console does
support expandable memory via microSD
cards up to two terabytes for its
battery the switch uses a rechargeable
4310 milliamp hour lithium-ion cell this
is a pretty big battery and it's more
than double the size of an iPhone 7
solution in Tendo claims that the switch
can last over six hours depending on
usage for zelda the company says users
should expect around three hours of
battery life from my testing this seems
pretty accurate
this system sleep mode itself seems to
be very power efficient after a full
charge I took the switch out of the dock
and set it aside for five hours when I
woke it up it still reported a hundred
percent charge as it is right now the
operating system is very simple in
bare-bones currently there is no video
player Nintendo said that video
streaming applications are being
considered for a future update at the
moment the OS allows you to do simple
things like calibrate your control
sticks test your internet connection and
going
airplane mode the Nintendo switch feels
like the culmination of years of hard
we're going paints from both Nvidia and
Nintendo
unlike the Wii U gamepad you no longer
have to worry about being tethered to
your TV because the switch has all of
its processing power in its portable
form factor it truly allows you to carry
console power with you wherever you go
the switch isn't perfect but it offers
multiple ways to play games all of which
are viable as silly as the commercials
may seem I can definitely see myself
bringing the switch to social gatherings
as much as I can see myself playing
Zelda sitting alone in front of my TV
you can find more powerful consoles like
the ps4 and Xbox one on sale for cheaper
than the $300 switch but you're paying
for the form factor here there's
something special about being able to
play breath of the wild on the big
screen and living room and then continue
where you left off outside should you
make the switch the answer should
largely depend on whether you think the
system's library of games will satisfy
your needs the Nintendo has undoubtedly
laid the groundwork for a great gaming
device
[Music]